we got to bring them in no not we me I'm
the reason Barry got lamby the women we
lose as a team
come with you I'm coming too look Jon I
respect this whole special agent
situation you got going on but this
problem right here needs some green skin
and a sick-ass cane call me the Martian
Manhunter I think you'll find the jobs a
lot more than just a pretty face okay
hello although barian cards idols are
all over the place let's go
[Music]
all right hello friends Kid Flash oh I'm
so glad you could join the party I'm
such a huge fan of your work but I have
to say recently your works been a bit
off you know I'm talking about I think
maybe it just said you're a little
scared and what happened in the
speedforce is that it no I'm not afraid
of anything
prove it flash almond is Tuesday at 8/7
central on the CW
[Music]
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video
what about musikmeister flash there that
is so crazy it seems like he stole
Barry's powers when he has the whammy on
him when he's in that dream state with
Cara so maybe he also stole cars powers
super strong indestructible speedsters
that's so crazy I feel like people
should watch the episode for that if for
nothing else so there's really like
three big things that we have to talk
about one the season for villains they
dropped a really big bomb to the mess
with Barry's character 3 the crossover
next season in a shadow forth smaller
crossovers between the shows like the
one they're having with Supergirl that's
kind of a special case because it's a
musical but I'm just talking about
having characters from one show go on
the other without it having to be like a
big four night thing the other big thing
is that Stephen Amell teased that he's
back on the island filming in the
flashbacks meetings that we're synching
up with the finale in the first moments
in the pilot
no even posted a picture of the
Deathstroke Matt so that's mostly for
continuities sake because that was like
one of the opening shots in the pilot
but they could always bring Deathstroke
back it was a really big deal it was
really cool like instantly I recognized
where he was when I saw this so all this
comes from the big PaleyFest panel I'll
add a link to that at the end of this I
basically cut it down to like all the
really important stuff they spent a lot
of time just being silly but there was
actually some really good information so
the first big thing the season four
villain is confirmed to not be a
speedster now I know a lot of you are
like didn't they say that in previous
seasons they were mostly talking about
the introduction of dr. alchemy in there
being like a really big overarching
villain that was somebody that was a
little bit different they weren't saying
that there wouldn't be any speedster
villains because the reverse-flash
is like the best example of a character
who will always be Barry's biggest
villain but you just can't use them all
the time so he's off on legends of
tomorrow this season he'll definitely
come back but when they say the big bad
won't be a speedster that just means
that the reverse-flash won't be the
person pulling the strings from behind
the scenes he'll have his own agenda
during the season we can talk about that
in a second because there is the once
and future flash episode I almost forgot
about that that should be like a whole
other video by itself so I'll talk about
that briefly and then maybe like later
this week I'll do a video about it but
the big villain so they always try to do
different characters that they've never
done before when it's like a big villain
twist but there are a number of ways
that they can use characters that they
already have in interesting twists that
could be villains in season four I know
everybody wants Eddie to come back for a
big season long arc and be like a cobalt
blue villain from the comics if you
don't know who that is it's a really
crazy comic book twist so obviously
there'd be liberal changes but he is a
long-lost twin of Barry Allen who was
stolen at Birth raised by criminals it
had a really bad version of Barry
Allen's good life like Barry Allen's
parents were amazing he turned out to be
this hero but his secret twin brother
was raised by a group of people
called the thawne's so he became
Malcolm's dawn so it was this twist on
the eel bars on family the reverse-flash
family so the only reason why that
wouldn't work as the big bat is because
he's kind of a speedster he has
speedster type powers even though the
source of those powers is more mystical
there's like a gemstone that powers in
the flat-out best non speedster villain
that they could go with they already
have on the show right now is the Rogues
you'd have to cycle the membership a
little bit but there are a ton of blasts
rogues that they haven't done yet mirror
master is the de facto leader this
season right now because Captain Cold as
those legends of tomorrow is still
missing in action he'll eventually come
back on the show alive and well and they
did say when he came back he would
definitely be evil so he'll be back to
his old rogue ways it would be great to
have him back on the main show but the
Rogues are just a really easy group to
cycle characters in and out of based on
actor availability you always want like
the biggest rogues but like heatwave is
probably going to stay on legend though
they'll introduce some new rogues no
matter what even if they're not the big
villains you could also go to mercury
labs there are a number of evil
scientists that used to work at STAR
Labs like dr. light they name dropped
him way back during arrow season two the
first time that Cisco and Caitlin ever
appeared on arrow they talked about dr.
light this crazy person with a bunch of
guns that they hadn't seen in a while
but he left all his equipment behind his
equipment belong to Arthur late well
fired him two years ago Washington he
was a psycho we want to use you Mystic
Falls
I think where I said I'll make this
quick
so there are a lot of very brilliant
evil scientists out there in the DC
Universe that used to work at STAR Labs
in the comics that they could always
bring back through mercury labs or some
other evil organization the other big
place they could pull from is the
multiverse so they keep getting bigger
and bigger with the flash like we went
to earth - last season the villain was
from Earth - now we have all these
characters from different earths
all over the place including cars earth
so they'll probably be human or someone
who used to be human or someone like
Grodd who's a creature from Earth but
still from earth so the really cool
thing that they've teed up but haven't
really addressed yet is that [ __ ] has a
father in the comics that is super evil
so she's from Earth 19 they could always
team up is a big bat he has powers that
go like way beyond what [ __ ] and Cisco
have but it's relatively similar he's
not a speedster but he's incredibly
powerful he had a really cool new 52
comic book story he's an interesting
idea if they ever want to do it so he's
in their back pocket but the other thing
is they really wanted to is they could
push Caitlin over the edge and she could
be one of the big bads for most of the
season now the reason I don't think
they'll do that even if she becomes evil
for any brief period is is because I
feel like they would go for a bigger act
or somebody that's a little bit older
with a little more experience talking
about episode 19 the once and future
flash I got so excited when I heard that
this was going to be the title of an
episode it's a seminal reverse flash
origin story whereby you Bart dawn in
the distant future is a super fan of the
flash he wants to come back in time to
meet him he wants to meet his hero like
anybody would but he goes to the wrong
time period goes to the flash museum and
secretly learns that he's destined to
become the reverse flash of villain and
then be killed by Barry Allen himself so
he learns about his own death it flips
him out and he starts masquerading as
Barry Allen to protect himself but Wally
West who's the main version of the flash
takes his ass and sends him back to the
future with no memory of what happened
so the episode version of the story will
be buried going to the future to try and
learn how to be Savitt are like he
decides he has to go to the future to
learn how things turn out so that he
could get more information but the last
big thing and this is a big
a true four night crossover next season
so technically Legends is on Tuesday
nights so it'd still be at 3:00 night
crossover but there before shows they
would just have a dedicated episode of
Supergirl it would tie in instead of
like the last ten minutes of the episode
that would be the big change they didn't
say who the big villains are going to be
they probably have an idea for it but
the even bigger story would be if they
did a legion story so if they wanted to
do like a big crossover with a really
crazy sci-fi twist I feel like they've
been building towards Legion on
Supergirl
so they'll eventually do it on one of
the TV shows but let me know in the
comments what do you want them to do for
the big four night crossover and who do
you want the flash season 4 villain to
be if it's not going to be a speedster
the musical episode is going to happen
tomorrow night I know a lot of you
aren't a big fan of the idea of the
musical I'll still do my Easter egg
videos so you can just watch that and
find out what happened even if you're
not going to watch the episode I'll
still be doing a flash ring giveaway so
no worries what's going to happen next
is I'll try to finish my Iron Fist
videos they'll be the flash episode and
one of the Avengers stars was talking
about how they would never crossover
with the TV show so that was like a
pretty big WTF i might do video for that
if you guys really want so
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Severn Valley PLEASE private
message being on the back end of my
channel there was a new round that
surgeons in this video announce the
winner when I post out the last episode